metro police say a child was thrown from
a third floor balcony in the southeast
part of town the person responsible
police say is now behind bars this
happened at the boulder pines apartment
complex on boulder highway south of
desert inn joe moeller joins us with
more on what people in the area are
saying
we are still waiting on an update on how
that child is doing this evening many
are still wondering what sparked a
person to throw a child from a third
story at this apartment complex when
police arrived they found the
five-year-old and a male who had been
shot both were transported to the
hospital we were told the adult male was
shot by a member of the child's family
during a struggle after the child was
thrown we spoke to tony hennessey who
lives nearby sickening
it don't make any sense why you would do
that to a child
even in a family dispute
why involve the children a man who lives
in the complex said yesterday he
witnessed an adult being taken into
custody that person also expressed
concern with the complex and the need
for more security we'll update you as
soon as more details become available
joe mohler 8 news now